hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and today
i'm going to spend a lot of time saying
i'm sorry what exactly is that because
sometimes this hunter hunter really
needs us to go
and dig up it's filthy as bugs to
understand exactly what's happening
and how it affects us really deeply
episode 76
this episode was a neat and interesting
introduction to a whole slate of new
concepts and characters as well as more
insight into the traits god and his
father share and while we all knew it
wasn't going to be
jing casually fishing right like we knew
we totally knew that we know his
preferences are flying on a dragon
flying on a dragon i didn't say that
twice i meant to say that
his preferences are flying on a dragon
flying on a dragon so the connection had
to be there since the reasoning was
pretty clear but before we go much
further we got a whole new theme song
with a whole new host of new faces and
what does that mean
a whole new slate of character names for
me to fail to learn and make up my own
for all that i say i don't read the
comments one thing has consistently
managed to get through my quick skims to
see your general vibe
that general vibe being my favorite
member of the military
yeah so that that vibe is you all want
chimera ant
i don't know what this chimera ant thing
is or what the chimera ant arc will be
about but there are ants in the theme
titles so
one can only assume that this is this
one this here is the moment you've all
been waiting for and i'll be honest i
truly thought it was going to be a
metaphorical ant or someone called
ant like anthony not actual ants
like really did takashi do that thing
where he researches deeply
into something then writes an entire arc
about that thing cause i'm baffled by
the concept of a queen ant sitting in a
cave gollum style eating fish to give
birth to the king ant
but we'll come back to that and all the
questions i have about bug people and
winged creatures and my general
confusion with everything going on in
this world that we've had absolutely no
indication could ever have been a thing
where does a giant ant come from and why
is that not something
that came up anywhere in this world
before or something that could exist
she's huge back to the beginning of the
episode and gone and killed our land in
this beautiful snow-like
magical petal fairy tale land after
traveling a long way to see his father
neg what they find is a strange at first
dude called kite with a swishy swishy
cape that goes swish swish and a clown
thing that maybe
randomly gives him weapons and like is
sassy at him i i don't
i am immediately confused because i
thought hunters were somewhat in control
of how their nen presents and apparently
either they're absolutely not or while
he was in training ching messed with him
and said hey hey you know what it would
be really funny if you just like
randomized your abilities do it and the
problem is with the image we've been
given of jing so far
someone who would tell his son he
doesn't want to meet him then set up an
elaborate plot to tell that son
that meeting him wait with the image
we've been given of jing so far someone
who would tell his son he doesn't want
to meet him then set up an elaborate
plot to keep that son from meeting him
while providing the most intensely
interesting and entertaining environment
in which to try to find someone then
decide that friends make that son weak
while asking his friend to program
something
don't think i didn't notice that i'm
coming back to it so with all those
random behaviors he does and the fact
that he'll just change someone's name
because
you know he does it he wants to he and
gone are perfectly matched if this
series were ever actually finished i
wouldn't be surprised to find it's a
loop and gone meets his dad taps him on
the shoulder says tag you're it
then runs off to hide it's the sort of
thing i would expect from this
particular family and that's why
see i didn't forget that's why i could
easily expect jing to mess with kite
like that see i got that i went back in
circles but we got there eventually stay
with me
jing and gone similarities are such that
we can see the desire to play in both we
can also see the impulsiveness
someone who would change a friend's name
to make game branding flow
as well as someone who would fight or
kill to protect those things he cares
about while wandering away from all
those things that he doesn't it also
seems
jing is just as capable of gathering
people around him who he can
ask or make do what he wants them to do
in fact sitting on the idea of
friendship for a moment it's fascinating
that jing decided gone could only see
him alone there's something in that that
speaks to the psychopathy
i attribute to gon why would a child
only be able to see their father alone
why would jing think god needs to
confront him or why would it be weakness
for him to be with a friend the fact
that jing didn't consider other reasons
for having a friend accompany you says
so much about him and his expectations
and engagement in relationships and
because i'm me maybe i'm looking at all
of this the wrong way and in fact
jing is also psychopathic it's psych
yeah not
yeah well he's also psychopathic
everyone he's helped he seems to have
put to work for him in some way
in the same way that gone helped kiwa
get out of his home jing seemed to have
helped
a slew of people what we don't know yet
is what
jing hunts and i'm starting to wonder if
he hunts and captures emotions so he can
put them to work for him
not so that he has friends hang on hang
on my husband's calling me
i like the blue ones the blue ones i
like the blue ones they're tasty and any
of those would be delicious
don't tell my husband i just had that
call he thinks i'm recording
actually i don't know that he doesn't
know i'm recording
i'm gonna put this to charge before we
move on after all the others who helped
him build greed island are
stuck on that island now sure it seems
out of choice but there are twins who
seemingly never leave their programming
room there are characters built into the
game for whoever may come along to reach
an end
game with he makes friends they feel
indebted and so they do what he wants
them to do which
seems to be just wait for years until
his young psychopathic son decides to
come join him and make things difficult
for that son
so that he's worthy of his father by the
time they do meet jing
ultimately is a very strange but
entirely predictable character
everyone who meets him thinks he's
wonderful so there are a lot of stories
myths and legends about him everything
anyone has to say about him makes him
seem
even more impressive so i wonder whether
meeting him will actually be a huge
letdown
ultimately despite the psychopathy that
seems to run through at least the male
part of the family the result is that
people are made better as a result huh
it's a strange symbiosis of society
people who don't care make people who do
care
do things that ultimately help society
not always and not often but in this
particular world of this particular show
that sort of seems to be the consistent
takeaway message what i did find strange
in this episode was that melody's theme
popped up while god and kite were
talking or at least
i've always called it that is his energy
supposed to be seen as similar perhaps
given his apparent affinity
with animals that every hunter has that
wasn't a thing before wait has he always
had an affinity with animals has that
always been a thing why have i never
yeah i want to know more about kite and
i'm sure it won't take
long for us to get to meet the king of
the ants so let's check out episode
77 episode 77 and we're going to start
with what i perceive to be the worst
thing about this series and work our way
back out of that pit
it's the seriously awful racial
portrayal of characters
throughout my reviews i've ranted about
the racist and sexist when it you know
gets really bad
undertones to the series on balance
canary is cool despite the mammy-like
depiction i was glad abengane yes i did
in fact look that up
snake monster guy avengane got to live
unlike blowpipe
goreta and squalor got a quick brief
development of backstory after being
humiliated and acting like a dog but
before being unceremoniously killed and
never thought of again
and those are the ones that stick with
me because i'm black unfortunately
perhaps
because of my own perspective on the
world that plays into my reviews and the
things i notice are pretty grim
this time i had to seriously pause
because lin
and podango were such incredibly awful
and
obvious caricatures that it wasn't just
the fact that kite called his companions
amateurs that told me they're not gonna
be around for long i had to stop
reassess whether i'm okay with watching
this and engaging with it before going
on
and that's before the rest of the crew
something we really need to be clear
about before i move on because i can't
talk about this forever and nor do i
want to
is that the show is a product of its
time and i understand that
it's from the 90s like mr popo and jinx
i just wanted to
experience the quest of a psychopathic
preteen searching for his father with
his assassin heart-eyed friend give me
that escapism i want it damn it please
just just the escapism
anyway the escapism part is good
except working back as i said i would
these friends of kites
oh man they gotta go we have a banana
something slow something bubble gum shut
up staring chick
nineties wannabe fro guy cow man and cat
dog
i'm just so excited for what the show
will become when my screen is not taken
up
by them to be entirely honest they're
all uniquely annoying in their own way
and i feel bad for saying that because
i'm sure they'd be really fun to watch
for someone
maybe at the end of the first half of
the episode i had a strange sense of
disconcert
probably a combination of what was
actually happening in the queen ant
storyline but majorly to do with this
group of people
when someone tells me they're not a
specialist in something but they're
doing research on it anyway my ears perk
up like a dog hearing dinner time
for kilwa to be the first person who
says hey so this is really long so we
should extrapolate that to mean the
creature could eat people
and then to tell them that the creature
eating whatever it eats
gains aspects of that food's genetics i
would be quarantining much more strictly
than it seems they have then telling
many more people than they have
that there is a serious problem where
did this queen come from
it's still an issue from before where
did she come from and how was this not a
problem before this hungry hungry queen
a game coming to liam and my shelves
this summer hungry hungry
queen sounds actually quite fun to play
she sounds driven
and focused on her goal in a way the
kids won't have experienced yet and
that's exciting
there's something frightening and
uncomfortable about your enemy being
hunger
it's like the idea of a black hole just
the concept of hunger
yes there's something behind it but at
that moment their enemy is just
something that wants to consume
and that's a great premise for an art i
suppose we can expect that aspects of
the group we've seen will all turn up as
members of her army when they do get
consumed so we'll see a cow man bug at
some point maybe an annoying bubblegum
bug or a spider
sort of creature i don't know but i'm
really hoping there's actually a purpose
behind them being as annoying as they
are
the fact that we start the ark at
children being eaten is
a good indication of where we're going
to end up start dark get darker it was a
surprise having children become a meal
but now that i know
that's the world we're stepping into one
in which the brother will look after his
sister forever then die anyway
prompting a massacre in the real world
because people are tasty
well let's let's just say stick dinners
will have a lot on his plate for a while
and you know what i'm gonna leave you
there with that joke because that's what
this episode deserves
if you'd like to see more hear more talk
more click here here
here and hang out on the discord where
things happen otherwise hit the like and
subscribe buttons and i will see you
next time